okay I tried to give it and get a quick
bite in there here we go
127 players 17 42 rating let's go
a lot of blunders are going to happen
definitely where's that little clock
okay I have the clock ready
Anand mover let's go what's going on
here this is going to give me a chance
to a down some Gatorade here we go
oh I needed that break I can use this
nan mover all right
okay um there's probably somebody that
already has three games in let's see if
I'm right give me the W what a game oh
what'd I tell you nine point somebody
has and this is the guy that has nine
points oh this guy has to go down let's
take this guy right out you need to go
hit that Queen
oh let's hit that bishop get out of
there bishop for Kurowski I could take
the bishop as well Oh Forks right here
Forks everywhere let's take this mine
that Bishop come to the rescue
Oh Forks everywhere Forks are flying
around everywhere I got the bishop come
on you know this is time to resign I'm
up a ton of material on here I don't
want ninety five stuff you check we're
here give a check here checks everywhere
no need to castle right here is fine
double these ropes here they're gonna go
after that pot let's do that
alright let's get rid of this night hang
on let's get rid of this bishop right
here to box out that night and then why
this should
okay let's pin that night and then I'm
gonna take that night here where the
mates where the mates looking for the
mates
checkmate
that's me back to tournament five whoa
how does somebody have 40 oh man this is
crazy what is happening what's happening
here okay I need a boost here I need a
boost and the age pot is gonna be my
boost dark square weaknesses everywhere
now let's go here dark squares focus on
those dark squares name of the game name
of the game name in the game right here
f6 kill a queen Oh deadly discovered
checks in the air whoa suicide right
there that's me that's me I'll take the
main 40 trees somebody has 43 that is
crazy this guy wants a try I don't want
a job I want to win I need to win how am
I gonna get catch 42 unless I win you
can't draw your way yes you could quick
resign your way to the top maybe 43 I
have 19 I'm in 10th this guys down here
with the 11 this guy's a good player 20
to 30 ah let's go let's go let's roll I
think I want to stop a pin ok let's see
if they I get give me the F file that
files where it's at
hang on to your bishop don't you dare
give that up right here give me the a
file incoming knight on f5 devastating
let's come over in this direction let's
come over here I'm scared
all right here my g3 all right let's get
rid of that I won't hit that clean take
my bishop already so I don't have to
keep pre moving that night h4 I want to
get to f5 and keep the Queens on the
board here we go ok it's an ugly
structure but I'm up upon it's ugly but
I'm up upon and upon his upon his upon
over here can keep your rook on the a
file how dare you take it off the a file
don't ever do that over here actually
over here at night can't move this night
needs to weasel around and he's gonna
weasel around right here hit this pond
hit this pond again and the rook is
gonna be on the defensive or is it yes
it is now I'm gonna push d4 no I'm gonna
take that guy no I'm not because they
had tricky stuff up their sleeve
now let's do this and get this guy next
let's get this guy next no let me give
it a check first and then come back here
and now I got that pun I'm watching out
for the entry points here on the F file
very important detail very important
detail let's come back over now those
guys are passed or doubled but their
past they're down they resigned 29 oh
man here we go anti network is on the
scene anti network oh is that a mouse
slipper let's go get that clean get that
clean I'm going right after see - lets
go oh hang on
big trouble big trouble here isn't it is
it big trouble grab this pun he's
important isn't he I'm torn apart let's
do this and then go further keep pushing
watch out for the dark squares let's
trade get my dark square bishop right
here get castled
I'm dropping that pawn clock situation I
get this right here
I get that pond let's break this open
okay
what's the scoop here what's the scoop I
got the F file I shouldn't just push
push again over oh no no no no no check
I'm gonna go with the rook I wanna get
that pun clock situation I have to take
that what's the scoop what's the scoop
here I don't have any time eight seconds
ah no time
where's the clock where's my time oh no
I had a check can I get this somehow can
I get it can I get it can I get it give
a check
I don't have any time
other downtime I was holding my breath
again man anti network goes down goes
down how many of you knew I was holding
my breath when you weren't hearing any
words like there he goes there he goes
holding his breath again I almost fell
for something right there let's go for
karu ski actually they could take here
with check they're not taking there
though
uh-oh this is a big trouble
actually I am I
I stuck in a couple bites of a turkey
sandwich that was just kind of coming up
right there TMI was that TMI right there
too much information we don't want to
know is what you were just topping up I
get here already watch out for the ports
discover tricks discovered tricks
everywhere there was also hook right
there to win the Queen that would have
been nice this is good enough though I'm
up full rook full rookie Mike when he
wants to be on e4 I want to save my
knight and my knight wants to give a
check here I could pretty much cream
with that one this Knight needs to go
somewhere else
so my clean can have fun over here or
can she can take this Knight as a pins
pins pins clean pawn check game is not
gonna end I need to pre move like crazy
where is the main
where is the main that's a mate back to
tournament it wonderful this guy is 35
games and what's happening here 35 games
this guy has Wow all right what's
happening there's a team effort here
team effort it's a team effort
this is another sneaky guy I think
there's another sneaky guy I'll take my
bishop I'm okay with that
get out of there Knight who I almost
moved the wrong time Oh incoming night
right there would have been good could
still be good probably is good avoid the
Queen exchange no I'll discover tricks
I'm the queen by force or not I should
grab the pine it would have been all
right
let's try it again it's too late for
that
you missed your mature maturity you
missed your opportunity don't try to do
that
I'll Forks everywhere works everywhere
yeah I know the tricks I know the tricks
come on you could still do it somehow
gonna take that pod let's come over here
they're taking that pond being sneaky I
know the tricks I'm in trouble I'm in
big trouble 14 let's do this trying to
get this in hit the Queen hit this
what's the scoop oh hang on
I have this
where the sneaky moves can I get the
Queen being sneaky not gonna fall for
that uh they're not gonna fall for that
ah man it's not working
should it work I'm down on time man
sneaky people everywhere the sneak
artists what can you do uh I shouldn't
have been so reckless right there
towards the end I think I could still
could have maybe somehow won that one
even though I was down at time and that
was really a good player in disguise
they're in disguise they're everywhere
they're everywhere you don't know where
you're gonna get hit with them okay my
Jeep on is gonna be launched I kicked
that night away and and do some damage
all right I got to do this I didn't
really want to do it but I'm gonna do it
oh I'm on the Queen and I'm on g7
let's break at h7 we get that in try it
for tricky mates that doesn't work
though just pawn defend that's a oh they
missed it I'm gonna take it though 60
nothing oh man 54 games what is that guy
doing what's that is so ridiculous Oh
quick resigner I'm in 17 I'm in 17th Wow
is there some crazy glitch that somebody
has 54 games in that's up top there
fishing poles where are the fishing
poles get out of there get out of there
no way you tonight you have no business
being there no business queenside castle
and now throw your Jeep on down uh-oh
Knight right here now I should well I
guess sorry
I'm gonna kick that night away let's do
this first
mmm take that and then I'm on the rock
I'm gonna take the night next otherwise
there is some pin stuff going on okay
where's where's the mate I'm get a mate
here
that's not leading to me mate once right
fall for it take that Bishop I know it
no they're not that's a quick main 98
somebody has 194 15 minutes halfway
there
nice um somehow I have to dodge all the
sneaky people along the way can I
somehow get this oh they're being crazy
they're being crazy they're saying come
get me they're saying come get me you
peek my head out come get me all right
I'm gonna try I'm gonna try to come get
you
it's just castle they're still saying
come get me I'm gonna try it
coming after you coming after you
incoming pivot square III g2h for with
the Queen let's go clean do some damage
check
this is made if they take you know you
want to take that's made back to
tournament one 18 to 23 is in first 59
games
new player has negative 139 and here's
another sneak artist 139 is all of a
sudden playing tricky stuff counter
tricks is this a counter trick I
actually lucked out with that and I
didn't realize I'd be getting that back
be great to be able to beat this guy be
great kick this night away let's stay
right here let's do this
get out of there Knight don't you dare
try and get active
okay uh-oh they must be scared let's go
where's the night gonna go let's go
uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh I got the night if the
pond pushes let's take here Queens are
off the board come on go click actually
kick that night away first
should I have this and play my rook here
I want to secure my net
I didn't mean to do that my king I
didn't mean to drop that pawn either
hang on to him come over here
let's come over here and let's push this
what's going on here oh there's a rook
check hang on to this that pot is
falling can I get a king move in forks
Forks get up here push that pond all
right right here they're actually down
on time ah who's down on time
I feel like it's okay to trash-talk in
these games because when they're being
sneaky like that and they're still
losing ah that's not fair
don't do that don't sandbag no
sandbagging allowed give me the rookies
look up and over look up and over the
kitchen sink variation the kitchen sink
right here the kitchen sink
come on me where's the mean what does
that mean don't you dare run away King
matin - matin - may have one check mate
just move come on yeah it's back to
tournament 158 299 68 games up there
ready to set a record let's go Bishop c4
f4 Knight f3 all right let's go right
after f7 right here pawn push tempo
tempo gainer tempo gainer Bishop takes
f4 I got the material back and now a
serious lead in development looking for
me right on f7 or take on f4
main threat I'm gonna see it I'm trying
to get a quick win that's a quick win f7
back to Charlotte 178 357 254 230 ok
let's go let's roll here
alright I'm gonna take that get this in
here Queen c7 you know it's being cooked
up right here you know it's being cooked
up move Knight move Knight just move
Knight man hang on
ok Forks just take that pawn ok light
squares let's play here I want to get to
f3 get that in set the queen that pawns
falling I don't have any time what about
night here
I still get some sneaky stuff in here
rook up and over Rick up and then over G
trees on I got two threats here either
one ok let's come back 19 seconds let me
get this pie my rook is kind of dead if
the pawn pushes let's stop it from being
dead sneaky sneaky stuff over here uh-oh
uh-oh
where are the tricks where are the
tricks checks more checks gotta guard
that pig get a pig right there
let's do this so I could get some time
burners in
Oh
don't have any time yes
move oh I forfeit on time my mouse
wasn't moving oh man ah did you hear all
that clicking it was it was a mate
I had a made one right there ah stupid
Mouse I want to throw it come on e7
pre move ah man but so I was struggling
you hear that thing I was clicking like
a maniac ah stupid Mouse I'm blaming it
on the mouse ah man I'm having
flashbacks of that one game where I got
beat with what I got beat with them my
bowling my opponent only had point one
seconds
ah those are tough to stomach ah man
that was made if I have ever seen a mate
was dad a mate right there ah man there
goes my Queen now she's still around
she's still around don't count her out
it's coming here I don't want to cast my
rook is fine where he is
let's get out of pins ah man I don't
think there's any hope for even top 10
yeah ah so now I'm just trying to
convince myself that it's okay to lose
that game you see that little trick that
was my little trick oh I wouldn't know
one in any how oh there's Forks if I do
that hang on beware the forks beware of
those Forks okay let's get to this
square can I get there stop that I want
to get to d4 my knight wants to be doing
stuff here we go they're down in time
play movers
okay let's go back check checks and
forks forks and checks forks and checks
tournament ah man
okay Frogger
I got a play against Frogger here let's
go Frogger Frogger is gonna get squashed
he's gonna get squashed right here yeah
I was so clever of you to say squash
right there you know that let's go break
this open but not so much I don't want
that square to be available for like I'm
taking on each three and I'm going right
after you King it's castle sneaky sneaky
okay let's go here now take my rook he's
free dark-squared bishop came to life
just then I want to get to where I want
to get to be five let's do this
let's do that what's the situation is
this another sneaky player I'm on the
night sneaky players everywhere
sneaky players everywhere Forks coming
up against me against me there's Forks
the king is a fighting piece that can't
be good can it could also take that
bishop the king is a fighter give a
check where are the tricks give another
check just for fun and come back here oh
that pounds finally let's do this is it
okay here if it saves say it's safe
please grab this pawn I'm in a pen the
king is a fighter he's a fighter
checks tricky knight tricky night let's
see if I can move him this time he's
still struggling to move kill a bishop
give a check
check go after these guys
ah I got that guy
more sneaky people more sneaky people
down Frogger kid another sneak artist
down Oh new player negative 191 now he's
gonna start playing now he's ready to
start playing three minutes and change
you better win this you better win if
you're going to have this time advantage
if you don't you're everybody's gonna be
mad at you okay
let's do this right here I'm still
trying to get it still trying to get it
oh oh let's do that double the rooks
double the rooks oh oh oh it's me
I better resign ah man that was made on
g2 they're just gonna milk my clock
that's okay let's do it
oh man that one would have stung 277 277
Queen c7 b5 Bishop e7 well I could block
that this guy is having a good
tournament I think he's one of the real
ones think he's one of the real ones out
there um actually I think I've played
this I play this guy earlier get that
pond maybe but these double ponds keep
in mind these ponds in the center right
here actually very good doubled pawns
not always a liability now the Knights
gonna play here I think I need to get
off one pair of rooks yeah I just want
one pair off and I'm actually
threatening this Knight and he's one
o'clock situation is pretty good they
can resign you get this and then that
and then this as well
hitting everything back determine 234
471 this is the top guy ah I'm gonna
claim success this is going to be for
the tournament win if I could get this
guy 471 I've never played a beast that
was that high rated or that that great
of a score Queen age five made threats
watch out for the tricky mates Oh
serious pressure serious pressure to win
rook up and over everybody loves to look
up and overtake that bishop take him
he's free Oh
pawn push coming up get out of there
Knight I cannot deal with you my queen
is dead my queen would have been dead
right there should have pushed rook
takes okay we're gonna have a bunch of
trades aren't we and at the end of it
can I still oh man I wanted to get that
one the tournament was called oh man
look at these scores have you ever seen
scores like this something is going
crazy here I'll still say good games all
even though there is a lot of suspicious
stuff happening oh my goodness 95 games
26 games a hundred and thirty three
games it's messy